เฮ [música]
[música]
>> [música]
>> Cho Olá,
[música]
pessoal. Tudo bem com vocês? Bom dia,
sejam todos muito bem-vindos e muito
bem-vindas ao nosso encontro de direito
civil de hoje. Estamos iniciando agora o
nosso terceiro encontro de revisão paraa
nossa pro nosso exame de ordem. Terceiro
encontro de sete encontros, na verdade
que nós vamos estudar as sete partes do
direito civil incansavelmente para que
você possa conseguir seis pontos na sua
prova. Nós já tivemos um encontro de
sucessões, porque a gente sempre estuda
de trás para frente, né? Nós já tivemos
um encontro de sucessões e nós já
tivemos um encontro de família também. E
hoje a gente vai estudar, seguindo essa
ordem reversa a parte de direito das
coisas. Vamos falar sobre alguns
aspectos importantes que podem ser
cobrados na sua prova dessa parte tão
especial do Código Civil que começa no
artigo 1196.
E um ponto importante, quando você
lembra de direito das coisas, você tá
estudando três aspectos:
vizinhança,
reais e posse. É, são três pontos dentro
do direito das coisas: vizinhança,
direitos reais e posse. A gente vai
trabalhar direitos reais em comunhão com
posse agora, levando em consideração que
direito real é aquele direito que
gravita em torno de um fenômeno chamado
propriedade.
Todo direito real tá previsto em lei.
Todo direito real está previsto no mesmo
artigo, no 1225.
Tanto que ele diz assim: "São direitos
reais a propriedade, superfície, uso
fruto, uso, habitação, direito do
promitente comprador do imóvel, direito
de laje, hipoteca, pen, anticrese, um
bocado de direito real lá. Mas quando
ele fala do primeiríssimo direito real
como sendo a propriedade, a gente vai
encontrar como a propriedade como sendo
um genuinamente direito real. Por quê?
Todos os outros direitos reais decorrem
da propriedade, mas vocês sempre ficam
eh preocupados em diferenciar
propriedade e posse. Gente, propriedade
é direito real. Posse não é. Posse é um
estudo separado que começa no 1220,
1190,
pera aí, 1196
do Código Civil. Então, pra gente tratar
desses temas de uma maneira bem
contextualizada, que é o que a FGV
gosta, a gente vai explicar fazendo os
nossos desenhos e aí seguidamente a
gente já dá algumas questões aqui de
como o tema já foi tratado, já foi
cobrado. E eu quero aproveitar e mandar
um beijo para todo mundo que já tá aí ao
vivo acompanhando a gente. Manda o link
pros seus amigos, pras suas amigas que
vão fazer essa prova ou que mesmo que
não vão fazer essa prova agora, que
precisam aprender um pouquinho sobre
direito das coisas. Então, café na mão,
caneta, vamos partir pros nossos
desenhos, vamos começar a entender como
que funciona essa história de
propriedade e de posse, tá? Eu quero
trabalhar com vocês agora esses dois
temas. Lembrando que propriedade é
direito real e posse não é direito real.
Nani não. Então vamos falar de direito
das coisas. Olha só, desenhando aqui os
nossos bonequinhos para poder ilustrar,
eu quero começar te contando uma
história de uma pessoa
aqui,
de uma pessoa que tem
a propriedade.
Essa criatura que a gente desenhou aqui
é chamado
de proprietário.
E quando a gente chama essa criatura de
proprietário, a gente tá dizendo que
essa criatura tem alguma coisa. Pode ser
um bem móvel, um bem imóvel. Eu vou
ilustrar para você aqui com um bem
imóvel, tá? Então o proprietário ele tem
em relação a esse bem específico
móvel ou imóvel
uma situação de atributos.
Quais são os atributos da propriedade
que nós temos? Nós vamos ter o grude.
A propriedade gruda na pessoa, a
propriedade gruda no proprietário.
Então, quais são os atributos da
propriedade? Gozar,
reaver,
usar
e dispor.
Então, o proprietário é aquele que tem o
direito de usar, gozar, dispor e reaver
o bem. Professora, qual que é o artigo
que eu encontro essa informação?
Isso aqui consta, eu vou abrir para
você, no artigo 1228,
que é o artigo
da negócio aqui. Pera aí, vamos lá.
Artigo 1000,
1228.
Tá vendo? O proprietário tem a faculdade
de usar, gozar e dispor da coisa e
também o direito de reavê-la do poder de
quem quer que injustamente possua ou
detenha, tá? Então o proprietário ele
tem o direito de usar, gozar, dispor e
reaver o bem. Essa é a dicção do 1228,
que é o primeiro artigo relacionado à
propriedade.
Se todos esses atributos, preste atenção
agora, se todos esses atributos
estiverem na mão do proprietário,
vou até botar mais para cá um pouquinho
nosso desenho, tá vendo? Se todos esses
atributos estiverem na mão do
proprietário, ele tem a propriedade
plena ou também chamada de propriedade
alodial. Vou desenhar a mão dele aqui,
ó. Se todos esses atributos
estiverem com ele,
todos estiverem com ele,
ele tem a propriedade plena. Então,
imagina, eu tenho uma casa e eu moro
nessa casa, eu estou no exercício do
direito de gozar, reaver, usar e dispor
do bem. Tudo bem? Agora pode acontecer
de eu ter uma outra figura em cena.
Essa figura
aqui, levando em consideração o que nós
estamos falando de propriedade, essa
outra figura aqui pode ser o denominado
possuidor.
Professora, como assim? Vou te explicar
como que entra
essa criatura
em cena.
O possuidor é aquele que exerce um ou
alguns dos atributos da propriedade.
Olha o artigo 1196.
Ah, professora, essa parte é difícil, é
nada.
Olha o que diz. Considera-se possuidor
todo aquele que tem de fato o exercício
pleno ou não de alguns dos poderes
inerentes à propriedade. Eu vou pegar o
1196,
vou colar aqui no nosso material
porque eu quero que você fique olhando
para ele incansavelmente.
O 1196
ele conceitua quem é possuidor. E ele
diz seguinte: é possuidor é todo aquele
que exerce
um
ou alguns dos poderes inerentes à
propriedade. Quais são os poderes
inerentes à propriedade? Usar, gozar,
dispor e reaver o bem. OK? Direito de
usar, gozar, dispor e reaver o bem.
Então, a gente combinou aqui que se
todos esses atributos estiverem na mão
na mão
do proprietário, ele tem a propriedade
plena. Ô, meu Deus, eu não desenhei
aqui. Ele tem a propriedade plena ou a
lodial, tá? Então, o direito de gozar,
reaver, usar e dispor. Se tiver tudo na
mão do proprietário, ele tem a
propriedade a lodial. O possuidor.
Possuidor é todo aquele que possui
o um ou alguns dos poderes inerentes à
propriedade. Então, imagina que essa
criatura aqui que a gente designou como
possuidor, ele está no exercício do
direito de gozar. Eu vou passar pela
casinha.
Pelo direito de gozar.
E o direito de usar, por exemplo,
veja, houve uma elasticidade dos
atributos. Os atributos ficam em parte
na mão do proprietário, em parte na mão
de terceiro. Quando os atributos
estiverem em parte na mão de terceiro e
esse terceiro puder exercer esse
atributo de maneira plena, esse terceiro
é chamado de possuidor.
Não cai com rotina, mas pode ser que
caia. Qual a teoria
adotada pelo Código Civil em relação à
posse?
De fato, o artigo 196, nós temos duas
teorias importantes, mas esse artigo,
especificamente
trata de uma teoria,
acho que ficou muito grande,
é porque eu, como eu vou desenhar tanta
coisa aqui, vou colocar aqui assim, nós
temos duas teorias, tá? Nós temos a
teoria subjetiva de Savini. Vou botar
assim, ó. Teoria
subjetiva.
Excelente nome, né? Para quem vai
adquirir um animalzinho de estimação,
vai adotar
subjetiva
de S vini
e a teoria objetiva
de um carinha chamadoing.
Olha só que interessante.
S com s, vogal com vogal. A teoria
subjetiva de Savenir é aquela que fala
que possuidor é aquele que tem a
intenção de proceder como proprietário.
Gente, nem sempre isso acontece, óbvio.
Imagina uma pessoa que aluga um
apartamento para morar por 2 anos, ele
não tem a intenção de proceder como
proprietário. Então, a teoria de Savini,
ela é uma teoria que justifica apenas e
tão somente a posse a de uso capionen,
que é aquela posse com a intenção de
adquirir a propriedade. Ele não
justifica toda a modalidade de posse,
porque nem todo possuidor tem esse
ânimus, né, essa intenção de adquirir a
propriedade. Então, fica um pouco inóqua
a a tese de Savenir. A teoria objetiva
de Ering estabelece que posse é apenas
corpos. E, infelizmente essa parte do
direito civil é uma parte muito
filosófica, né? Posse é uma parte muito
filosófica, não é não é palpável, não é
tangível. A posse é um direito eh
diferente. Tanto que a doutrina
civilista entende a posse como várias
possibilidades de natureza jurídica.
Dentre uma das naturezas jurídicas é
sugêneres. É uma coisa o quê? que não se
encaixa em nada que já existe.
Mas a teoria objetiva de Ering é aquela
teoria que fala que posse é corpos,
posse é o contato com a coisa, é
simplesmente você ter ali eh uma relação
de
de contato mesmo. Veja, eu estou com
essa caneca na mão, eu estou na posse da
caneca. Pronto. Então é o contato com a
coisa. E aí você vai entender que o
contato pode estar na mão do
proprietário quando ele tem a
propriedade plena ou não, pode estar na
mão de outra pessoa. Quando você pensa
na propriedade plena, é maravilhoso,
porque tá tudo na mão do proprietário,
né? Ele
ele eh
ele tendo tudo ali, o proprietário ele
tá no contato com a coisa. Então a gente
quando quando você pensa em
proprietário, em possuidor ali nessa
relação, você pensa na elasticidade
desses atributos. E aí você vai lembrar
de uma classificação muito bacana que é
possuidor direto.
Possuidor
direto
e possuidor
indireto.
Só que essa classificação só faz sentido
quando os atributos da propriedade
tiverem realmente sido transmitidos a
alguém. Então, o possuidor direto é
aquele que tem o corpus, é aquele que
tem o contato com a coisa. Então, quando
a gente fala de possuidor,
a gente tá falando de possuidor direto.
Quando você estuda posse, você tá
estudando possuidor direto. O possuidor
indireto é o proprietário. Quando a
gente tem essa transmissão
dos atributos da propriedade. Então, se
o proprietário tá com tudo na mão dele,
a propriedade plena, usar, gozar, dispor
e reaver o bem, a gente não vai falar em
possuidor porque tá tudo na mão dele.
Mas quando isso passa pra mão de outra
pessoa, o gozar, o usar, por exemplo,
você tem o chamado possuidor, que é quem
tá no corpos, que é quem tá no contato
com a coisa, né? Se tudo tá na mão do
proprietário, não faz sentido a gente
falar de possuidor. Então, quando você
observa essa teoria de, é possível que
você que você enxergue, na verdade, o
proprietário e o possuidor, ainda que
eh
ainda que
não especificamente
no campo dos atributos, tá?
E é bom você observar
que
quando você visualiza o possuidor direto
e o possuidor indireto nesse campo, né,
da da teoria objetiva de Ering, você
pode visualizar a posse
diferente do domínio, diferente do da
propriedade, porque realmente são coisas
diferentes e é possível você ter o
exercício da posse e o exercício da
propriedade concomitantemente.
Proprietário é proprietário,
proprietário é proprietário e possuidor
é possuidor. De modo que imagina o João
tem a propriedade do apartamento e ele
aluga o apartamento para Maria. Maria é
locatária ou ele empresta o apartamento
gratuitamente para Maria. Maria é
comodatária.
Quando você enxerga isso, você percebe
que a Maria tem a posse e o João tem a
propriedade. Tanto são coisas diferentes
que um não pode incomodar o outro nesse
aspecto. A Maria não pode impedir o
exercício da propriedade de João do
tipo, se o João quiser vender o bem, ele
pode, porque o atributo de dispor do bem
continua na mão dele. E o João, que é o
proprietário, ele não pode atrapalhar
a posse da Maria, de modo que ela tem o
direito de usar e gozar do bem. Ele não
pode, por exemplo, um exemplo esdrúchulo
aqui, a qualquer tempo, chegar e entrar
no imóvel alugado para Maria sobre o
pretexto e fundamento de que ele é o
proprietário. Ele não pode fazer isso
porque uma coisa é uma coisa, outra
coisa outra coisa. Uma coisa é a posse e
outra coisa é a propriedade. São coisas
completamente diferentes e que não se
confundem entre si, tá? Então, feitas
essas considerações,
eu quero ainda te dizer que nós temos
uma classificação muito importante de
posse, tá? Além da posse direta e
indireta, eu tenho classificações
importantes de posse. Eu vou escrever e
depois eu faço a bolinha, porque senão,
né, vocês já sabem.
Eh,
você já ouviu falar em possuidor de boa
fé?
e possuidor de má fé.
Professora, o possuidor de boa fé é o
gente fina e o possuidor de má fé é o
desgraçado vagabundo que invadiu o
imóvel. Não necessariamente.
Primeira coisa que você vai tirar da sua
cabeça é que possuidor de uma fé é o
cão, é o demônio. Não é isso.
O conceito de possuidor de boa fé é
simplesmente aquele que ignora
vícios.
E possuidor de má fé é o contrário. É
aquele que não
ignora
vícios.
Gente, possuidor de boa fé não é o
demônio. Ou o de uma fé não é o demônio.
Vocês imaginam assim: "Ah, o possuidor
de uma fé é aquela pessoa que invadiu,
que matou todo mundo, que tomou a
propriedade para ela, é o desgraçado
vagabundo." Não é, não é. O conceito de
possuidor de boa fé e de má fé é
simplesmente
a relação de saber ou não de vícios.
se a pessoa sabe ou não sabe de vícios.
Vou te dar um exemplo que já caiu em
prova. Eu comprei o apartamento do João.
O João me vendeu o apartamento por R$
500.000. Eu fui lá e paguei pro João e
eu comprei e eu tô morando no
apartamento. Por um fato da vida, sei lá
o que, falta de grana, enfim, a gente
não transferiu o imóvel. Mas eu tenho um
documento que comprova que eu paguei pro
João.
Eu não transferi, não fiz a escritura
pública, né? Porque eu não tinha
dinheiro para pagar o imposto e também
não transferi pro meu nome porque eu não
tinha dinheiro para pagar as as taxas
cartorárias. E isso acontece todo santo
dia. As pessoas compram imóveis e não
transferem os imóveis, acabam demorando
para transferir o imóvel. E aí eu tô lá
morando neste apartamento que eu
comprei, que eu paguei do João. Eu te
pergunto, eu tô de boa fé? Tô. Tô. Claro
que eu tô. Mas eu tô de boa fé porque eu
sou gente fina? Não, eu tô de boa fé
porque eu não imagino vício nenhum
naquela estrutura ali. Agora imagina que
do Neida, do Neida, eu acordo um belo
dia, aquele dia que começa igual o cão,
né? Eu acordo um belo dia e nesse belo
dia que eu estou lá iniciando, fazendo
meu café, porque comigo é assim, quando
o dia começa uma merda, pode ter certeza
que no momento que eu tô tomando meu
café já começa a merda esculhambando
tudo de uma vez. É sempre assim. Então
eu tô lá tomando meu café
e de repente o oficial de justiça bate
na minha porta e fala assim: "Você é a
Roberta?" Eu digo: "Sim, sou. Pelo amor
de Deus, o que que eu fiz? Olha, eu vou
te entregar uma ação judicial aqui
promovida pela Antônia, que se diz
proprietária desse apartamento que você
mora. Eu digo, como é? Mas, rapaz, eu
paguei pro João esse apartamento. Eu
comprei esse apartamento do João. Pois
é, mas essa ação reivindicatória aqui da
Antônia contra você dizendo que o
apartamento é dela e me entrega a
petição inicial.
Gente, nesse aspecto, nesse aspecto você
precisa ter consciência. Eu, Roberta, me
tornei uma pessoa do mal, né? Ha, vamos
matar todo mundo. Não, não, eu continuo
sendo gente fina, eu continuo sendo
bacana. Mas a partir do momento que
surge uma pulga atrás da orelha aqui, ó,
da merda que pode dar, eu passo a ser
possuidora de uma fé. Então, o possuidor
de uma fé não é o invasor, não é o que
quebrou o portão e entrou, não é o que
matou o proprietário e tomou dele, não.
Possuidor de uma fé é aquela pessoa que
não ignora vícios, ou seja, falando o
contrário, é aquele que sabe que pode
dar uma merda no exercício da posse
dele. Entendeu?
Entenderam isso? Eu sou o proprietário
de uma fé. Imagina que o pai morre e os
filhos vão iniciar o processo de
inventário e um dos filhos fica morando
na casa que era dos pais. Veja, esse
filho que tá morando na casa que era dos
pais, ele precisa ser uma pessoa
horrível do cão do demônio, desgraçado,
maldito, vagabundo. Não, não. Ele tá
morando ali porque ele não tem para onde
ir.
Ele tá, ele sabe que ali não é o lugar
dele, ele sabe. Então, ele é um
possuidor de máfé.
Má fé não é a pessoa do cão, entenda
isso, tá? é só aquela pessoa que sabe
que pode dar uma merda no exercício da
posse dele. Além disso, eu quero que
você entenda que nós temos uma outra
classificação de posse, que é a posse
justa
e a posse injusta. Vocês também adoram
confundir essas duas aqui. Posse justa,
o conceito parece até uma sacanagem, mas
o conceito da posse justa é exatamente a
posse que não
é injusta. Ah, Roberta, é sacanagem.
Calma, muita calma nessa hora, muita
hora nessa calma. Relaxa. E a posse
injusta é a posse que é obtida com
violência
agora é o sujeito do cão, do demônio,
com violência,
clandestinidade.
Clanestidade.
Ah, eu vou escrever de outro jeito. É a
posse que é violenta.
violenta
clandestina
ou precária?
Professora, é aqui que eu morro de ódio,
que eu não entendo o que que é isso.
Calma que você vai entender agora que eu
vou te dar exemplos. Posse violenta,
clandestina e precária. Essa é a posse
injusta.
O que que é a posse violenta? É a
criatura. O possuidor que ao entrar na
posse usa da violência, né? Derruba o
portão, derruba o muro, dá uns tabf no
proprietário.
Se você pensa,
eu posso ter posse de bem móvel ou
imóvel, de boa, isso aí você já sabe,
né? A posse é sobre a coisa e a coisa
pode ser um bem móvel ou imóvel. Quando
você lembra do roubo, infelizmente a
gente tem que lembrar do penal, né?
civil é muito melhor que penal, mas
nessas horas aqui a gente tem que usar
os exemplos do penal. Quando você pensa
no roubo, o que que é o roubo? É alguém
que toma uma coisa móvel de outra pessoa
com violência, né? Então, o roubo ele é
uma posse violenta. Aqui pro direito
civil, quando você pensa no roubo, o o
ladrão tá pegando a posse do bem do
outro
na base da pancada, na base da
violência, você tem uma posse injusta. E
isso pode ser tanto do aqui, né? É só um
exemplo, uma analogia, mas aqui pode ser
tanto do bem imóvel quanto do bem
imóvel. Então, se a pessoa invade a
fazenda de alguém e toma esse bem, isso
é uma posse injusta. Se tiver havido
violência por violência, que a gente
chama de esbulho violento. O esbulho é
quando você tira a pessoa da posse, você
retira a pessoa da posse. Esse esbulho,
ele é violento quando a pessoa usa
efetivamente da violência. Agora, se
você vai lá, pega o negócio ali no na
surdina, na calada da noite, a gente já
tem uma posse clandestina. Você pega, se
assemelha muito ao furto. Você pega a
coisa ali, ninguém tá olhando, eu vou lá
e pego. Ou na calada da noite eu invado
a propriedade e tomo para mim. Isso é um
esbulho que a gente chama de esbulho
meio que pacífico, né? Não tem
violência. O o esbulho clandestino
se assemelha muito ao furto. E a posse
precária, que é uma posse injusta, mas
para mim é a mais filha da pi de todas.
Por quê? A posse precária, ela pauta no
começo com uma confiança, se assemelha
muito à apropriação indébita, indevida,
das coisas dos outros. Eu alugo o
apartamento para você, o contrato de
locação tem o período de vigência de 12
meses. Você ficou morando lá por 12
meses, pagando o aluguel bonitinho.
E aí de repente o contrato de locação
termina e eu falo: "Me devolve o
imóvel". você tem que me restituir um
imóvel e você não faz. Você continua num
imóvel sem pagar aluguel, sem
autorização. Isso é uma posse precária.
A posse precária é aquela que é uma
continuidade de uma posse que havia eh
que era uma posse justa. E você passa a
ter uma posse precária, que é aquela
posse na qual você tinha uma
autorização, uma permissão pautada na
confiança, no né, na fidúcia ali
existente entre as partes. E você não
restitui o bem, não devolve o bem no
momento que deve devolver. Imagina que
eu vou fazer uma viagem pros Estados
Unidos, eu não sei quanto tempo eu vou
ficar lá. Comprei só a ida. Deus um dia
ainda vai fazer uma uma glória dessa na
minha vida. Comprei só a ida. E eu digo
a você, olha, eu queria muito deixar
os meus cachorros na sua casa. Eu queria
deixar a minha quadrilha de animais na
sua casa. Posso? E aí você fala: "Pode,
Roberta, pode deixar aqui comigo que eu
cuido." Isso é um contrato de depósito.
Ah, Roberta, mas os cachorros até que
mude o nosso ordenamento jurídico e a
gente crie um terceiro gênero, os
animais são coisas, são bens móveis,
considerados bens móveis por
deslocamento de força própria, que são
os serentes. Então, por isso que a gente
fala, eu não posso deixar um testamento
pro cachorro, porque o cachorro é objeto
do testamento. Então eu deixo os
cachorros com você na sua casa. Isso é
um contrato de depósito. Aí eu falo para
você, quando eu voltar, eu quero que
você me devolva o cachorro, mas eu não
sei se eu vou voltar daqui dois, três,
quatro ou 5 meses. Mas o fato é que eu
voltei e aí eu volto e te notifico para
você me devolver os animais. E aí você
não devolve, você começa a ter uma posse
injusta por precariedade dos meus bens.
OK?
Então essas, é óbvio que a gente tem
mais um monte de classificação de posse,
né? Posse nova que tem menos de um ano e
um dia, posse velha que tem mais de um
ano e um dia. E você não pode confundir
posse velha, posse nova com ação de
força nova e ação de força velha, porque
ação de força nova é aquela ação
possessória proposta há menos de um ano
e um dia da moléstia possessória, que é
o esbulho ou a turbação,
independentemente se é posse nova ou
posse velha, na verdade seria uma posse
velha.
Eh, posse nova é um uma característica
meramente objetiva e classificatória. A
gente também tem a classificação de
posse A de interdita e po posse A de uso
capionem. Posse a de interdita é a posse
tradicional do possuidor direto. A posse
a de uso capionen é aquela posse com
ânimos de adquirir a propriedade. Essa
posse a de uso capionen é a posse que é
levada em consideração para fins de uso
capião, tá? A gente vai fazer o quadro,
né, do coração aqui de uso capião já já.
Então essa é a ideia. Só que a gente
ainda tem um terceiro elemento aqui, que
vocês vão ficar chocados com ele, que é
o zoudinho, o nosso zoiudinho querido,
que ele eh fica ali olhando, fica ali
cuidando, mas ele não não é possuidor.
Essa criaturinha
que cuida ali,
vou desenhar ele aqui de vermelhinho.
Ele é,
vamos fazer o olhão dele bem grandão.
Ele está ali amando
por ordem
ou do proprietário.
Ele está ali por ordem ou do
proprietário
ou de um possuidor que coloca essa
criatura lá, tá? Ele tá por ordem do
proprietário ou do possuidor que coloca
ele lá. Esse essa criatura consta no
artigo 10008.
Vou botar aqui em cima, ó. 1198.
E sabe qual o nome dele?
Detor.
O detentor
ele também é chamado
de pâmulo da posse. Professora, que
diabo de nome é esse? É, vamos colocar
porque vai que, né? Pâmulo da posse. Ele
também é chamado de gestor da posse dos
outros.
Ele também é chamado de servidor da
posse.
Servidor
da posse, tá? Ele tem uma relação com a
coisa em nome do proprietário ou em nome
do possuidor. Professora, quem são essas
pessoas? Me dá o exemplo. O nosso
clássico exemplo do caseiro. Tem coisa
melhor?
O caseiro, ele é categoricamente
um sujeito detentor. Ele vigia a casa,
né? O caseiro, o vigia mesmo, o vigia de
uma casa, ele é o detentor. O
bibliotecário, quem lembra do
bibliotecário? bibliotecário.
Vamos botar esses exemplos aqui em
relação à biblioteca. Ele é um detentor
no que tange os livros que ficam sobre o
controle dele. Que mais que a gente pode
lembrar aqui? Eh, o operário de uma
fábrica. o operário da fábrica em
relação ao maquinário, né, do patrão
dele, ele é o detentor, o detentor de
posse alheia, ou seja, ele é um
subordinado
do real possuidor ou do proprietário.
Então, ele tem uma relação de
dependência.
Esse cara ele exerce, presta atenção,
atos
de mera
custódia. Ele cuida só. Ele cuida. Ele
cuida porque ele tem para com o
possuidor ou o proprietário
uma coisa que a gente vai anotar aqui.
Ele tem dependência econômica,
dependência,
dependência
econômica
ou mero vínculo
vínculo de subordinação.
Então eu quero anotar isso aqui de Q a
gente não é besta. Vamos deixar isso
aqui muito claro.
Vou puxar aqui uma setinha,
tá? Ele tem uma dependência econômica
com um vínculo de subordinação. Ele
exerce atos de mera custódia.
Agora, o que que eu quero que você
observe
com muito carinho? Presta atenção o
detentor. Então eu vou até colocar aqui
de maneira diferente.
É porque eu sou um pouco lerda, né,
gente? Vocês estão vendo que eu podia só
ter arrastado para cá.
Pronto. Ele tem um vínculo, ele tem um
vínculo de dependência econômica ou de
subordinação. Ele exerce esses atos de
mera mera custódia. Ó, Anaiara, eu sou
bibl bibliotecária. Obrigada,
professora, por citar minha profissão
como exemplo. Tá vendo que maravilhoso?
Olha aí. Você é detentora dos livros
dos livros da biblioteca. Você é
detentora, você está descrita no artigo
1198.
É o Zoiudinho que fica ali tomando conta
dos livros da biblioteca. Legal, né?
Você tem uma dependência econômica ou um
vínculo de subordinação para com o dono
da biblioteca, né, ou o possuidor da
biblioteca. Então, olha só que
interessante.
Vamos trabalhar com o exemplo do
caseiro.
O exemplo do caseiro. O caseiro, ele tá
lá tomando conta da casa,
de modo que ele não é possuidor e ele
não é o proprietário. Então, ele não tem
nenhum atributo.
Ele não exerce nenhum direito de gozar,
nem de usar, nem de expor, nem de reaver
o bem. Ele é um mero mero detentor. Ele
é o fâmulo da posse. Ele é o quê? O
gestor da posse alheia.
Mas professora,
será que
o detentor
ficando muito tempo num imóvel, por
exemplo, o caseiro da fazenda, que fica
lá na fazenda por
30 anos, tem caseiro que fixa um
vínculo, né, com o proprietário de
muitos anos e aí ele fica ali o caseiro
com 30 anos, os filhos crescem lá,
enfim, e o caseiro ele acaba morando lá.
né? A minha pergunta é: em algum momento
esse caseiro pode, por ficar ali muito
tempo, adquirir a propriedade pela uso
capião? Não, não, não, porque atos de
detenção não geram consequências de
posse. E uso capião é uma consequência
da posse a de uso capione, daquela posse
subjetiva que a gente já conversou sobre
ela. E eu vou fazer o quadro do coração
já. E a diz que usa o capião. Alô, uso
capião. Então não vai rolar. Não vai
rolar. Olha o que que diz aqui o 1198.
Considera-se detentor aquele que,
achando-se em relação de dependência
para com o outro, conserva a posse em
nome deste e em cumprimento de ordens ou
instruções suas. Aquele que começou a
comportar-se de modo como presescreve
esse artigo em relação ao bem ou a outra
pessoa, presume se detentou até que
prove o contrário, tá? E um outro artigo
importante aqui, ó. não induzem posse os
atos de mera permissão ou tolerância,
assim como não autorizam a sua aquisição
atos violentos clandestinos, senão
depois de necessária violência ou
clandestinidade. Então, a gente tem dois
dispositivos que deixam muito claro o
que que não vai ter efeito de posse.
Atos de mera permissão ou tolerância,
atos violentos clandestinos, se não
depois de cessar a violência ou
clandestinidade. E o nosso queridíssimo
menininho aqui detentor, ele nunca vai
nunca vai adquirir a propriedade da
fazenda, porque ele tá lá como caseiro
tem 30 anos, 50 anos, 60 anos. Nunca,
nunca. Mas algo precisa ser dito. E eu
quero te contar uma história agora para
te explicar um ponto muito interessante
que já foi cobrado no exame de ordem.
Então, olha essa questão aqui que já foi
cobrada pela FGV. Tema. Eu vou fazer o
nosso a nossa placa da atenção
e você vai prestar atenção no que a
gente vai contar, porque essa questão
aqui a gente consegue explicar muita,
muita, muita coisa por meio dela. Então,
se liga no esquema. Vamos lá.
O tema do coração, presta atenção. O
João
era caseiro,
aí já desperto plinamente, né? Era
caseiro da
dona Maria.
Da dona Maria. Ele era caseiro da dona
Maria desde
1980. Eu tô inventando aqui os dados,
mas a questão era mais ou menos assim,
né? Como dizia Chicó. Não sei. Só sei
que foi assim, desde 1980. E ele morava
com a dona Maria
lá na casa da dona Maria, que era uma
mansão bem grandona.
Em 2010,
2010,
dona Maria,
dona Maria faleceu,
tá deixando cinco filhos
maiores
e capazes
que nunca Nunca quiseram
saber do imóvel lá da dona Maria, nunca
foram lá.
O João ficou meio descompensado depois
da morte da Maria, mas beleza, vida
seguiu.
E o João,
o João
permaneceu,
permaneceu
morando na casa da Maria. Os filhos
nunca foram lá. Ele falou: "Cara, eu vou
é morar aqui." Ele permaneceu morando na
casa e ele ainda passou a ocupar
o quarto da Maria.
Ele foi se recolher ao repouso no quarto
da Maria.
Ele passou a alugar
a garagem
para o vizinho
e fez reformas
no imóvel,
tá? Fez reformas no imóvel.
Em 2022 do Neida,
os filhos
chegam e falam assim: "João,
a gente quer a devolução do imóvel de
nossa mãe. Muito obrigado por ter ficado
aqui cuidando e a gente pede a
desocupação
deste imóvel. Agora,
olha que questão sensacional. Olha que
questão maravilhosa. Dá pra gente tirar
um monte de informação aqui. Primeiro eu
quero que você observe, e eu vou usar
algumas cores diferentes aqui.
Vou usar o verde pra gente começar a
observar o momento em que o João é
caseiro. O João
é caseiro de 1980
até o ano de 2010.
Então veja, de 1980,
a 2010, ele era efetivamente o quê?
Detentor.
Ele tinha um vínculo de subordinação com
a Maria. Se ligou no esquema? Percebeu
isso aqui?
Ele era um detentor. Só que em 2010,
em 2010 a Maria morre.
Olha lá, em 2010 a Maria faleceu.
A Maria faleceu. Ele continuou morando
neste imóvel Brasil.
E ele foi ocupar o quarto, alugou a
garagem e fez reformas. E ele ficou
assim até o ano de 2002.
2022.
Eu quero saber o que que aconteceu com
ele do ano de 2010 até o ano de 2022.
Ele é detentor nesse período, gente,
cuidado,
porque agora é o pulo do gato. Olha que
sensacional.
Se a detenção é mantida pelo vínculo de
subordinação
ou e ou dependência econômica, a partir
do momento que se rompe esse vínculo de
subordinação e ou dependência econômica
e a pessoa continua tendo contato com a
coisa,
a gente vai ter o quê? a gente vai ter o
rompimento do vínculo. Então, quando a
gente fala de vínculo de dependência e
de subordinação, sabe o que que pode
acontecer aqui?
O rompimento,
o rompimento do vínculo de subordinação
ou dependência econômica. E havendo este
rompimento, produção Brasil, presta
atenção. Havendo esse rompimento,
surge um fenômeno chamado posse. Olha
que sensacional.
Então, se ocorre o rompimento e a pessoa
continua tendo contato, porque posse é
corpus eing 1196,
ele passa a ser possuidor.
Maravilhoso. Então, nesse período
amarelo que a gente anotou aqui, de 2010
a 2022, o nosso querido passou a ser o
quê?
simplesmente
possuidor,
professora, ele sendo possuidor. Agora
vamos lá que eu quero ver se você
entendeu mesmo o que eu falei. Ele
passou a ser possuidor. Ele tá de boa ou
de má fé?
Que que você me diz? Eu quero que você
me diga aí no chat. Ele tá de boa ou de
má fé?
Olha o conceito de possuidor de boa fé.
É o que ignora vícios. Possuidor de uma
fé é o que não ignora vícios. A minha
pergunta é: se você é funcionário da
dona Maria, vamos fingir que você é o
João.
Você é o João.
Aí a dona Maria morre. Aí você dá uma de
doido e continua morando lá no imóvel.
Você tá de boa fé ou de má fé?
Lembra? Pelo amor de Deus, eu vou entrar
nesse computador, eu vou socar a sua
cara. Olha para mim. Lembra que eu falei
para você que possuidor de boa fé
é aquele que ignora vícios?
Possuidor de boa fé é o que ignora.
Possuidor de má fé não é a pessoa do
cão, do demônio, do capeta. Não é aquele
que invadiu. Não é aquele que deu uns
taberf na Maria. Quem matou? Não.
Possuidor de uma fé é aquele que tem
ciência de que ali não é o lugar dele.
Ele tem ciência,
reage pra vida, reage pra vida. É aquele
que não ignora o vício. Deixa eu te
falar, o João, ele, rapaz, você tá
morando na casa dos outros.
Você sabe que ali não é tua casa. Você
tá de boa de mafé?
Ó o povo retratando a mensagem no chat.
Eu quero é que retrate mesmo.
Bora. Diga aí para mim. É óbvio.
É óbvio que ele tá de má fé, gente.
Pelo amor de Deus. Jorge Mateus, ele tá
de má fé.
Larga de ser feio.
Deixa de feiura.
Ele tá de uma fé. Ai, Roberta, mas o
João é tão bonzinho.
E eu não tô nem aí para isso.
Eu quero saber se ele sabe ou não ou não
que ali não é o lugar dele. Ele sabe.
Então, pronto, ele tá de uma fé.
Tudo bem, sensacional. Aí em 2022 ele
chega pros filhos da Maria e ele precisa
responder alguma coisa, porque os filhos
da Maria também, né, tão tudo de
fuleragem, tudo fuleiro e ruim. Eles
chegam do nada e fala: "Ah, João, tá
bom, agora sai, vaza". O João vai falar:
"Como é que é, meu amigo, você acordou
hoje e tomou o quê de café da manhã?"
Comer cocô. Eu não vou sair. Mas eu não
vou sair por quê?
Será que o João é considerado
para fingir uso capião?
Que que você me diz? Será que o João
pode ter adquirido a propriedade pela
uso capião?
A Amanda já colocou ali. Resumindo, ele
pode usar capi. Será se será se como que
funciona essa história? Eu vou para a
lâmina seguinte, paraa página seguinte,
mas eu vou voltar nessa.
Deixa eu te falar uma coisa aqui.
Vamos fazer o quadro. Aliás,
quem é que lembra?
O povo tá aqui. Eu acho que não. Eu acho
que sim. Deus,
que que é isso? É o telefone. Quando
você entra em pânico
para saber,
você disca
usucapião.
Alô, Usocapião.
Como que funciona? Qual é o telefone?
Olha a Alana prestando atenção na aula.
15 anos caiquim.
10 cai.
Alana. Você é Adorei. Curti, viu?
Essa tá de olho na aula. Alana, qual que
é o dis que uso capião aqui?
Alô, uso capião. 15
5 5 2 15 10 5 Adorei. Agora botei
fé. 15 10 55. 1552.
15 10 552. Onde tem 15 cai cinquim, onde
tem 10 cai cinquin. 552.
Gente, presta atenção. Esses são os
prazos da uso capião de imóvel.
Ai, professora, quanto tempo esse homem
ficou aqui no imóvel? De 2010 a 2022.
Ele ficou de 2010
a 2022. Eu não vou considerar de 1980 a
2010 porque ele era só detentor e
detentor não induz prazo de posse. Então
ele ficou de 2010 a 2022, certo? Ele
adquiriu pela uso capião, professora,
não visualizo nenhum prazo que encaixa
isso, mas vamos fazer o nosso quadro
aqui do coração. Vamos lá. Preparados?
Ao final da aula eu volto pra gente dar
aquele print categoria em todos os
slides. Vamos lá.
Se liga aqui no ponto prazo de uso
capião. A gente vai simplesmente dividir
o nosso quadro aqui, né? Como vocês
sabem que eu tenho toque,
eu vou usar a minha régua
K de Q.
É isso. Então vamos lá.
Que cor que vocês querem? Vamos fazer eh
laranja.
Vamos dividir aqui a primeira.
Não vai ficar exatamente igual, né? Que
vocês sabem.
Professora também não dá conta.
Oh.
Pois muito que bem,
professora. Quais são as modalidades?
Vamos anotar
agora. Pois muito que bem. Vamos lá.
Olha lá, a gente tem a modalidade
extraordinária,
modalidade ordinária,
rural,
urbana.
Pró família.
Então,
quem tá lembrando aí
ordinária, extraordinária?
Rural urbana para família. As três
últimas
são modalidades fofinhas,
existentes
para fazer o bem pros outros. Então, a
gente coloca nossos coraçãozinhos ali,
porque essas modalidades são modalidades
especiais para poder fazer o bem, tá?
a rural e a urbana são modalidades
previstas na Constituição Federal,
tá? Constituição Federal. Por isso que
os requisitos dessas modalidades não
podem ser alterados por legislação
ordinária, porque os requisitos são
constitucionais.
Profe, então tá entenditos
agora. Vamos lá. A parte de uso capião,
ela começa no artigo 1238,
tá? 1238.
No 1238,
a gente tem a modalidade da uso capião
menina aqui
extraordinário,
tá?
No 1239
a gente tem a rural. Vou botar os
artigos aqui, depois a gente coloca os
nossos eh requisitos.
No 1200
40 a gente tem
a urbana
a a prófamília.
E no 1242
a ordinária.
Todas elas todas elas exigem
o exercício
de um fenômeno chamado posse. Então, a
gente vai colocar aqui, ó, posse,
posse,
posse.
Professora, posse mais o quê?
tempo
mais intenção.
Então, lembra que eu falei para você que
a posse é que a usucapião exige
ali eh
a intenção de adquirir a propriedade
como se proprietário fosse.
Lembra disso?
Pois bem,
dentro da sua cabeça
tem que ter assim: "Eu quero ser
proprietário daqui, eu quero ser
proprietário daqui." E, puf, passou o
tempo
e esse tempo e você com essa intenção,
com essa vontade,
ou seja, para fingir uso capião, não
basta o contato com a coisa, não basta
você convocaring,
você tem que convocar Savini e falar:
"Amiguinho, o que que eu preciso? Eu
preciso de contato e intenção. Então,
minha cabecinha precisa ter a intenção
de ser proprietário. Isso tem que est
enraizado na minha mente e no meu
coração. Por isso eu coloco aqui para
você
o nosso cérebro
pensando,
ohó,
bonitinho
na minha intenção de proceder. como
proprietária, tá? Meu cerebrinho
pensando aqui bonitinho na minha
intenção de proceder como se fosse
proprietário.
Então, não basta
não basta
ter o contato, eu tenho que ter a
intenção. Então, eu vou colocar aqui
minha posse
e aí a minha caneta, né? resolveu dar um
pequeno pau aqui, mas é o que tem para
janta. Vamos lá. Eu tenho que ter a
minha posse com a minha intenção e mais
outros requisitos. Vamos lá.
O toque aqui é tão feio que eu tô
tentando catar esse cerebrinho aqui para
ele subir, mas eu não consigo. Então ele
vai ficar ali embaixo por enquanto. Já
já eu cato ele. Então vamos lá. tiver
intenção. Agora eu tenho que observar
que além da intenção, eu tenho que ter o
prazo. Qual que é, qual que é a o meu
prazo? Diz que uso o capião.
2.
Viu o telefone?
15 o quê?
Anos. 10 o quê? Anos. Cinco. O quê?
Anos.
Se você na extraordinária, que é a mais
fodástica de todas, fechar esses
requisitos, você adquiriu a propriedade.
Tchau e bênção. Posse intenção 15 anos.
Na ordinária você tem posse, intenção e
o que Brasil 10 anos. Só que ainda tem
um outro ponto. Sabe o que que você
precisa
de justo título
e boa fé? professora. Então quer
dizer que na extraordinária eu posso
estar de máfé? Claro. A maioria das das
modalidades de uso capião, modalidades
não, a maioria dos casos de uso capião,
a pessoa tá de uma fé.
Claramente, claramente. Cade que ela não
tem o que fazer da vida, né?
Então eu preciso de justo título e boa
fé. Se eu chego para você e falo assim:
"O que que você prefere? Um título ou um
justo título?
Um título ou um justo título? Que que
você prefere? Eu tenho na minha mão
direita um título e na minha mão
esquerda um justo título. Eu falo:
"Escolhe um dos dois". Que que você vai
escolher? Larga de feiura. É óbvio que
você vai escolher o título.
O título é aquele documento lá do
cartório que confere a sua propriedade.
É óbvio que você quer um título. Todo
mundo quer um título.
O justo título é qualquer documento
outro. qualquer documento outro que
possa conferir a boa fé do sujeito. E
quando a gente fala de boa fé na
usucapião, não é a boa fé objetiva,
principiológica, o padrão comportamental
ético que a gente trabalha como
princípio, né, baldrame ali axiológico
do direito civil. Não, aqui é a boa fé
subjetiva, na qual a gente leva em
consideração os aspectos subjetivos
daquele sujeito. Então, pode ser um
recibo, inclusive recentemente saiu
decisão do STJ nesse sentido. Pode ser
um recibo, pode ser um contrato de
promessa de compra e venda, é qualquer
documento que não o título que dê a
aparência de boa fé, a ficção da boa fé
para aquela pessoa. Todo mundo já ouviu
falar em grilagem de terra. O que que o
grileiro faz? O grileiro é um invasor,
ele invade terra privada ou terra
pública. Ele dá à aquela pessoa que
comprou, que tá querendo comprar, na
verdade, uma aparência de que ele tem
uma legitimidade naquela posse. Então o
que que ele faz? Ele falsifica o
documento do imóvel, né? E nossos pais,
né, os nossos avós, o pessoal mais
antigo tem um orgulho danado das suas
escrituras públicas de imóvel, de
propriedade do imóvel. Alguns guardam
embaixo do colchão, outros guardam no
cofre. Meu pai guarda no cofre. Olha só
o tamanha importância para essas pessoas
desse documento. Aliás, a propriedade
imobiliária desde a sua gênese no Brasil
é um dos direitos mais ricos e
importantes que nós temos. Por isso a
gente tem uma estrutura muito formal em
relação a esses direitos. E aí o que que
acontece? O pai da gente tira aquela
escritura, aquele papel envelhecido e
fala: "Olha aqui, é a propriedade da
nossa casa". Isso acontece muito. Hoje
em dia é mais fácil você tirar a segunda
via, né? dos documentos, dos cartórios,
a tecnologia facilita que você tenha
acesso a isso. Mas o povo da das antigas
lá não tinha aquele documento e
guardava, olha, tem que guardar seu
documento. Então o que que o grileiro
faz? Ele falsifica aquele documento,
coloca numa caixa com grilo, as feeses
dos grilos envelhecem o papel dando uma
aparência de papel antigo para você
acreditar que aquele tem a legitimidade
daquele bem. Aí ele vai lá e te vende.
Você tá de boa fé.
Aquilo pode ser um justo título. Aquele
documento que ele te entrega pode ser um
justo título para conferir a sua boa fé.
Só que para aferir a boa fé subjetiva, a
gente tem que levar em consideração a
pessoa, né? O professor Pablo, eh, nas
aulas, ele conta uma história mais ou
menos assim, que ele foi fazer uma
audiência como juiz numa ação
possessória e o senhorzinho era réu e
ele pergunta pro senhor: "O senhor sabe
o que que o senhor tá fazendo aqui?" E
ele falou: "Não sei, mas eu comprei um
um imóvel, uma uma era uma uma
fazendinha, uma coisa pequena, uma área
rural, uma pequena terra rural".
E aí o o juiz pergunta: "Você conhece
esse homem aqui na audiência que era o
autor que se dizia esbulhado, um homem
robusto, né? E aí ele dizia: "Conheço,
ele me vendeu o imóvel e eu tenho aqui o
documento que ele me vendeu e ele tira
do bolso uma escritura pública feita à
mão. Para ele aquilo era algo que
concedia a boa fé dele, porque ele
acreditava realmente naquele documento.
Agora, para nós que temos, né, o
conhecimento de como é a estrutura
documental de um imóvel, você não tem
como ter uma boa fé com base numa
escritura pública feita à mão, porque
você sabe que não é assim que faz. Mas
para aquele senhor, de repente era o que
ele tinha em mãos e que dava ele a
crença, a acreditação
da boa fé e da legitimidade do exercício
da posse dele, que se confundia naquele
caso com a propriedade, porque ele teria
acreditado na compra do imóvel. Então, o
justo título e a boa fé é aquilo que eh
te dá a boa fé.
Eu já não consigo aplicar essa
modalidade pro nosso João aqui, porque a
gente já definiu que ele está de uma fé
e a rural, urbana, pró família, que são
para fazer o bem, né? A modalidade rural
você vai ocupar o quê? Óbvio, a área o
quê, gente? Rural. Você não vai ocupar
área urbana. Então você vai ocupar área
rural. Área rural de o quê, professora?
Até 50 haares.
Até 50 haar. Tornando essa terra óbvio,
produtiva,
fixando a sua moradia
sua e de sua família. Então, não venha
dar uma de doido e achar que é só ocupar
a área rural e não dar uma destinação.
Se você ocupa uma área rural e não dá a
destinação, você pode usapi pela
modalidade extraordinária, mas pela
modalidade rural, que são 5 anos, tem
limitação de tamanho e tem um requisito
positivo, tornar a terra produtiva e
fixar a sua moradia.
A urbana você vai ocupar
área
de até
250 m²,
né? 250 m².
Você não vai tornar produtiva porque é a
área rural, mas você vai fixar a sua
moradia porque como é, tá vendo o
coraçãozinho aqui pro bem? Eu tenho que
ajudar a pessoa e eu vou ajudar quem
precisa.
Além disso, você tem um requisito
negativo aqui que não existe nos demais.
Esse requisito negativo é o que
justifica o coraçãozinho ali atrás.
É o que justifica o coração. Professora,
que requisito negativo é esse?
não
ser
proprietário
de outro
imóvel,
não ser proprietário de outro imóvel,
tá? E eu pego esse mesmo requisito aqui
e transcendo ele para cá,
porque aqui também não pode,
já que nós estamos falando da parte
fofinha, né?
Então esse requisito aqui negativo, ele
é exclusivo para modalidades fofinhas,
tá bom? Ele é exclusivo para modalidades
fofinhas, modalidades aí para fazer o
bem,
tá? E vamos lá. A prófamília, a
prófamília também tem o limite de
tamanho, é imóvel de até 250 m²,
que você fixou sua moradia,
mas esse imóvel você dividia com o
inferno
que abandonou o lar.
Abandono
do lar.
O abandono do lar, ele é aquele caso,
não é a separação de fato. O abandono do
lar, gente, é exatamente a pessoa que
sumiu, se picou,
foi-se embora, escafedeu, desapareceu,
né? Arlindo Orlando total
sumiu, desapareceu, escafedeu e não
voltou mais.
Esse é
esse é o abandono do lar.
Na na nas relações familiares, é muito
comum antes de você resolver o divórcio,
você ter uma separação de fato ou uma
separação judicial. É muito judicial. Eu
defendo que continua existindo, mas você
vai levar paraa sua prova que não existe
mais, né? Então é muito comum você ter
uma separação de fato, a pessoa já sai
de casa até para não matar o outro, né?
Pelo menos de ódio, eh
não dá mais para ficar junto, enfim, foi
viver a vida.
O separado de pato
não abandonou lá.
É a pessoa que sumiu, que foi comprar o
cigarro. Exatamente, Guto. E nunca mais
voltou. Sumiu, desapareceu. E aí, pelo
regime de bens ali, comunhão parcial ou
comunhão universal,
você tinha uma divisão desse bem com a
pessoa, uma ameação desse bem e a pessoa
sumiu. Você vai fazer o quê? Vai ficar
eternamente esperando o alecrm dourado
voltar, né? Porque no começo você achou
que era o presente de Deus e depois
descobriu que era só uma lembrancinha.
Ou no começo você achou que era o
presente do Papai do Céu e depois você
descobriu que era o presente do Papai da
Terra. É o ordinário. E aí ele não
volta. Aquela pessoa que ficou exercendo
a aposta exclusiva do bem, ela vai
adquirir
a propriedade inteira, né? Então ela vai
adquirir a propriedade dos 125 m².
Mas aqui também, gente, a gente tem o
requisito negativo. Como é para fazer o
bem
e não para gerar o enriquecimento sem
causa,
não pode ser
proprietário
de outro
imóvel.
Se cair na sua prova assim, ah, para o
Zucapir não pode ser proprietário de
outro imóvel errado.
Para capapir nas modalidades fofinhas,
nas modalidades eh tradicionais,
extraordinária e ordinária, você pode
ser proprietário de outro imóvel
tranquilamente. Eu posso ter 50 imóveis
e ainda uso capi mais 1, mais 2, mais 3.
Basta preencher os requisitos. Tudo bem?
De boa. Agora tem um detalhe aqui do
coração. Produção,
voltando no nosso exemplo, o João
adquiriu ou não adquiriu a propriedade?
Que que você me diz? Adquiriu ou não
adquiriu? Reage pra vida. Ele ficou de
2010 a 2022. Conta aí para mim quantos
anos
reage produção. Cadê vocês no chat?
E aí, a Lana já respondeu? Ali
veja, ele ocupou o imóvel.
Ele ocupou o imóvel,
passou a dormir no quarto da Maria,
alugou a garagem.
Deu quantos anos isso aqui?
Quantos anos de posse, né? Porque o
tempo de detenção eu não vou
contabilizar.
E fez reformas.
E fez reformas. Isso aqui é importante
pra gente. Essas informações aqui são
relevantes. Sabe por quê? Porque veja o
seguinte, ele ficou aqui por 12 anos.
Professora,
12 anos só poderia ser a ordinária,
mas ele não tem boa fé e ele não cumpriu
o prazo da extraordinária. Muito
cuidado. Sabe por quê?
KQ, produção,
existe uma modalidade abreviada.
Lembra que a gente ficou falando que cai
cinquim, cai cinquim, cai cinquim. Pois
é, existe uma modalidade
abreviada.
Professora, como que é essa modalidade?
A modalidade abreviada é a que cai
cinquin.
Cai cinquim. Cai cinquim de onde? Pelo
amor de Deus. Do tempo.
Vamos fazer bonito, né?
que esse quadro aqui, deixa eu te falar,
esse quadro aqui eu devia vender.
Cinquin, professora, me mostra aí o
artigo. Mostro. Vamos lá. No 1000
238.
Olha lá. Aquele que por 15 anos, sem
interrupção nem oposição, possuir como
seu um imóvel, adquire-lhe a
propriedade, independentemente de título
e boa fé. Modalidade o quê? Produção
extraordinária.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo abrir aqui,
ó.
Oh, não foi.
Vamos lá. Eh, podendo requerer ao juiz
assim o declare por sentença, a qual
servirá de título para o cartório de
registro de imóvel.
Parágrafo único, cai cinquinho. Olha lá,
o prazo estabelecido nesse artigo.
Reduzir-se a a 10 anos se o possuidor
houver estabelecido no imóvel sua
moradia habitual ou nele realizado obras
ou serviços de caráter produtivo. Ah,
professor, então o abreviado é isso. Cai
cinquinho, cai cinquinho, cai para 10
anos.
Se a criatura
tiver realizado o quê?
Realizado o quê?
Mentira. Tiver fixado moradia.
Moradia.
Tá. Moradia.
É isso mesmo.
Ou ou realizado obras, ele fez tudo
ou
tiver realizado serviços
de caráter produtiva.
Cristian, um beijo, viu? Um beijo.
Que bom te encontrar aqui.
Então, tiver realizado, ter fixado
moradia ou realizado obras de caráter
produtivo, serviços de caráter
produtivo.
E a nossa ordinária, como é que fica?
Ordinária
também adquire a propriedade do imóvel
aquele que, de forma contínua e
incontestadamente,
com justo título boa fé, possuir por 10
anos. Mas cai cinquinho, né? Será de 5
anos o prazo previsto nesse artigo. Se o
imóvel houver sido adquirido de maneira
onerosa, ou seja, você pagou por ele com
base no registro constante no respectivo
cartório, cancelado posteriormente esse
registro, desde que os possuidores
tenham estabelecido sua moradia ou
realizado investimentos de interesse
social ou e econômico. Então cai
cinquinho aqui,
5 anos. a modalidade ordinária
abreviada.
A modalidade ordinária abreviada. Se eu
tiver adquirido de maneira onerosa,
pagando
por ele, houve o cancelamento
do registro.
Vou escrever mais para cima aqui.
Cancelamento
do registro. Não é registro não, viu? Do
registro
e tiver estabelecido
a moradia.
Cai cinquinho.
Então que que o João vai responder ali?
Será que é possível aplicar a uso capião
extraordinária?
Que que você me diz? Será que é possível
aplicar a uso capião extraordinária?
Fala aí para mim.
É, ele ocupou por 10 anos. Então eu
aplico a modalidade de uso capião
extraordinária.
O quê? Produção abreviada.
Fala para mim.
Se você acertaria essa questão na sua
prova,
fala para mim. Sensacional. Por que que
eu tô aplicando a abreviada? Porque ele
ocupou o quarto, ele alugou a garagem,
ele fez reformas, ele fixou então a
moradia dele, ele fez obra, ele deu
destinação, ele deu uma função social ao
imóvel, então cai cinquinho. Não é
sensacional isso, gente? Muito
maravilhoso. Eu fico chocada.
Direito das coisas é muito maravilhoso.
Agora vamos lá falando o povo. Não, não
acertaria não. Não acertaria, não
acertaria.
É isso.
Agora depois dessa maravilhosa
explicação, ô Morgana, um beijo, viu?
Obrigada.
Vocês já querem dar os prints?
Dá o print nessa tela aí. Eu vou
continuar a tela, mas já dá o print
nessa.
3 2 1
Me deu vontade de adotar dois gatinhos e
colocar o nome de Ering e Savini.
3 2 1
a modalidade urbana precisa de boa fé. A
lei não fala, né? Ela fala aqui, ó. Ó,
aquele que possuir como suário urbana de
até 250 m² por 5 anos, ininterruptamente
e sem oposição, utilizando para sua
moradia de sua família, adquire o
domínio, desde que não seja proprietário
de outro imóvel urbano ou rural,
tá
beleza?
Tal qual a prófamília,
tá?
e a rural aqui no 1239.
Show de bola.
E deixa eu te falar, preencheu os
requisitos, adquiriu a propriedade.
Eventual ação para reconhecer a uso
capião, ela tem natureza declaratória.
Ou seja, vou demonstrar pro juiz que eu
adquiri a propriedade, o juiz declara
que eu tenho uma propriedade. Ele não
constitui a minha propriedade, porque
preenchidos os requisitos, eu já sou o
proprietário. Então, a o reconhecimento
da usucapião é sempre com uma natureza o
quê? Brasil declaratória. Beleza? Segue
o bonde. Dá uma olhada nesse nesse nessa
outra questão aqui. Lembra que eu falei
aqui da venda e biibi bobó? Então vamos
lá. Vamos lá. Olha só que legal.
Imagina
você também. Vou fazer aqui o nosso
nossa placa da atenção.
Eu sempre faço esse desenho. Essa placa
é de atenção mesmo, né?
É que eu acho bonitinho.
Olha só. Outro
detalhe, outro detalhe.
Imagina você o João, gente, olha essa
questão que ela é muito top. O João, em
ele comprou
o apartamento
do José, ou seja, o José é vendedor,
tá?
E ele pagou R$ 500.000,
foi lá e deu dinheiro pro José.
Em 2007
ainda,
basicamente em fevereiro
de 2007,
ele alugou esse apartamento. Ele comprou
para alugar. Ele alugou
para a Maria
que pagava R$ 4.000.
de aluguel,
tá? Então, a Maria aqui
é a tal da locatária.
Até aqui,
historinha normal da tradicional família
brasileira.
Em 2015,
João estava fazendo o café da manhã dele
e chega o Meirinho, que é o oficial de
justiça.
O João
recebe uma citação
logo em janeiro de 2015
de uma ação
reivindicatória, ou seja, uma ação
reivindicando a propriedade
proposta por Emília,
na qual Emília
se diz
proprietária,
dizendo assim: "Juiz,
seguinte, é esse
o José vendeu pro João, mas o José não
era proprietário. O proprietário sou
eu."
Então, ela se diz verdadeira
proprietária e ela faz os seguintes
pedidos.
Ó o pedido que ela faz, excelência, eu
quero a devolução do imóvel,
a devolução do imóvel, porque eu sou a
proprietária, eu quero que ele saia de
lá e me entregue um imóvel. E eu quero,
se esse pedido for procedente, né, aí eu
tenho aqui uma acumulação sucessiva de
pedidos. Excelência, eu quero a
devolução do imóvel. Se for devolvido o
imóvel, eu quero também a devolução.
A devolução
de todos
os aluguéis
recebidos
desde 2007, porque eu sou proprietária
desde desde antes disso. Você entendeu o
que que ela fez?
Entendeu? Então vamos lá. O João, ele tá
de boa ou de má fé?
Porque a minha pergunta é o seguinte.
Minha pergunta é:
se rolar uma sentença
de procedência
do pedido principal
da devolução do imóvel,
porque realmente é proprietária.
O juiz vai julgar também procedente,
porque como é uma acumulação sucessiva,
se o juiz julga procedente o principal,
ele analisa
o pedido sucessivo, não necessariamente
ele concede, né? A minha pergunta é:
será procedente
a a devolução do imóvel? com a
procedência da devolução do imóvel, será
procedente a devolução
dos aluguéis
desde 2007?
Que [roncando] que você me diz?
Primeiro você tem que lembrar que
aluguel, aluguel, aluguel é modalidade
de acessório chamado de fruto,
fruto civil.
Minha pergunta é:
o possuidor devolve os frutos
polidos?
aluguel, rendimento, são frutos civis.
O possuidor devolve os frutos. Ah,
professora, aqui eu lembro que depende,
depende, depende. Depende de quê?
Depende de uma coisa. Vamos aqui na
nossa lei
falando aqui, subindo aqui até a parte
de posse.
Olha aqui,
efeitos da posse. Quando a gente fala de
efeito da posse, a gente sempre tem que
lembrar que o que se leva em
consideração para fingir efeito da posse
é se a criatura tá de boa ou de má fé.
Muito que bem. Então o seguinte é esse.
Olha lá, o possuidor,
o possuidor de boa fé tem direito,
enquanto ela durar, aos frutos
percebidos.
Enquanto ela durar aos frutos
Tá aqui, ó, 1214.
O possuidor de boa fé tem direito,
enquanto a boa fé durar, os frutos
percebidos.
O possuidor de uma fé responde por todos
os frutos colhidos e percebidos. Então,
1214 diz
1214.
O possuidor de boa fé fica com os frutos
recebidos.
1216.
Possuidor de uma fé
devolve
os frutos.
Só que eu quero saber o seguinte, a
criatura tá de boa ou de má fé?
Porque eu já te expliquei, possuidor de
boa fé é o que ignora vícios. Possuidor
de má fé é o que não ignora vícios.
O João tá de boa de máfé. Vamos lá. Se é
uma questão de saber do vício, a gente
tem um ponto importante aqui.
Ele comprou em 2007,
ele alugou em 2007.
Você concorda que ele só teve ciência
que poderia dar uma merda em 2015
com a citação?
Então, de 2007 a 2000, de fevereiro de
2007 a janeiro de 2015, ele tava de boa
fé. Então, olha lá, em
fevereiro
de 2007
a janeiro de 2015, ele estava de boa fé,
porque só a partir de janeiro de 2015 é
que ele não mais ignorava vício. Então,
se ele não mais ignorava vício, ou seja,
ainda que ele fale: "Porra, mas eu
comprei, eu vou me defender e biibi bau
bá, eu vou me defender, eu vou me
defender. Nós estamos diante de uma
situação de má fé. Não é porque
ele se tornou uma pessoa ruim, horrível
do cão do capeta, não. É porque ele
começou a saber da merda que poderia
dar. Então ele tava de má fé. Então,
nessa questão, o que que a gente informa
que eu tenho, eu tendo a procedência da
devolução do imóvel, eu não vou ter a
procedência total da devolução de todos
os aluguéis.
Eu vou devolver a partir de quê? De
janeiro de 2015. Então o juiz não vai
jogar procedente, ele vai julgar
parcialmente procedente,
parcialmente procedente para devolver a
partir de quando?
Para devolver a partir de quando? A
partir de 1 de 2015. Então, se a ação
terminou, sei lá, em 2022, ele vai
devolver de 2015 a 2022, né?
Sensacional,
maravilhoso, show de bola. Agora, só um
detalhe, o José vendeu
o que ele não poderia ter vendido
e o João perdeu o que ele comprou para o
verdadeiro proprietário. Qual é o nome
dessa situação jurídica?
aquele que vende o que não poderia ter
vendido e quem comprou perde o bem para
o verdadeiro proprietário. É uma
situação do cão mesmo, né? Porque o cão
é muito articulado. Então aqui a gente
tem o quê? Evção. Evicção é a situação
do cão. É a situação da pessoa que
vendeu o que não poderia ter vendido. E
quem comprou se ferra porque perde o que
comprou para o verdadeiro proprietário.
Então a gente chama essa situação. Vamos
anotar.
Dá o print nessa tela. Já já eu volto em
todas as telas para você dar o print.
Categoria.
Vamos lá. Olha lá.
Evção, professora. O que diabo é
evicção?
Vamos evicção. Vou botar com letra de
forma.
Evic
é a situação do quê? do cão mesmo, é a
situação do cão, ou seja, evção é a
perda do bem para o verdadeiro
proprietário. Ou seja, que que eu vou
ter aqui?
Isso aqui é garantia contratual, tá? Mas
como a gente já falou ali naquela
questão anterior sobre um caso que gerou
a evicção, vamos falar dela agora porque
ela também tem reflexo no processo.
Ela tem reflexo no processo. Vamos ver
quem é que lembra. Qual é a historinha
básica aqui do cão. A historinha do cão.
Vamos anotar.
Quem
vendeu?
Não
poderia
ter
vendido.
E quem comprou?
perderá
o bem
para
o verdadeiro
proprietário.
O nosso exemplo aqui,
quem vendeu
o inferno do José? Quem comprou?
O pobre do João,
o Pob. E quem é o verdadeiro
proprietário? Emília. Ohó. Então, o que
que rolou nessa ação?
Emília.
Emília
ajuizou a ação contra o João.
O João vai apresentar toda a defesa que
ele tem, né? Ele vai apresentar toda a
possibilidade de defesa, mas ele vai
dizer assim: "Juiz, cara, vou me
defender aqui, mas se der merda pro meu
lado, eu quero que o José seja condenado
a me indenizar".
Ou seja, ele promove uma ampliação dessa
ação da Emília contra o João,
apresentando o João contra o José. Qual
é o nome disso? Lá no processo civil a
gente chama de
denúnciação
da LID, que uma vez eu pedi para um
aluno ler e ele leu Denunciação da Lide.
Denunciação da Laide. Deixa eu te falar,
a denunciação da LID é obrigatória? O
José, aliás, o João, quando citado na
ação proposta por Emília, ele é obrigado
a denunciar a Líd José? Não. Ele pode
esperar a ação terminar. Depois que a
ação terminar, ele promove a ação contra
o José ou ele já chama o José pro
processo. Então a denunciação da LID não
é
obrigatória, é uma intervenção de
terceiros
que não é obrigatória, você faz se você
quiser.
Certo?
Beleza? Pois muito que bem. Segue o
bonde. Já estamos entrando na reta final
de direito das coisas. Mas eu quero te
contar uma história.
Imagina você
que
a gente tem uma situação
muito peculiar, específica. Dá o print
nessa tela aí.
E gente, o pobre do João, ele pode
cobrar tudo que ele teve de prejuízo do
José, o que ele gastou com advogado, o
que ele investiu no bem, a toda,
tá? Então vamos lá. Olha só, imagina
você
o seguinte,
a minha régua,
K de qu, né?
De um lado eu tenho uma situação, de
outro lado eu tenho outra e eu não quero
que você confunda. Vamos lá. Imagina
você que aqui são as árvores.
Ai, professora, que diabo é isso que
você tá desenhando
aqui? É uma área verde [risadas]
aqui.
Aqui
é
a negócio aqui, ó.
Ah, gente, eu não sei desenhar direito,
tá? Mas é é o que tem pra janta.
Quem é que sabe o que que tá acontecendo
aqui? Ninguém. Mas enfim,
aqui eu tenho lote A,
lote B,
lote C.
Aqui é a pista, né?
Tá vendo que o fundo dos lotes tudo dá
pro negócio aqui, pra área verde. Então
esse povo aqui só sai pra frente.
Ó o carrinho.
Ó o carrinho aqui.
Só sai pra frente,
entendeu? Vem um carrinho aqui e entra
aqui, entra aqui, entra aqui. Ele só sai
pra frente.
Esse primeiro lote aqui é da Maria.
Esse segundo lote aqui,
[risadas]
o povo tá falando que minhas árvores
parecem uns ETS, gente. São árvores, tem
maçãs.
Vocês criticam os meus desenhos.
Olha só.
Olha só. Condomínio. Não é condomínio. O
segundo lote aqui é do João
e o terceiro lote aqui é do José.
Esses lotes são bem grandes. Aí o João
dá uma de doido e fala assim: "Cara, meu
lote tá muito grande, eu não tô ocupando
ele inteiro, então eu vou fazer o
seguinte, eu vou vender o fundo."
Aí ele divide esse lote dele em dois e
vende o fundo para o Mário. Que Mário?
Esse aqui mesmo.
Mário não é tatu para sair pelo chão e
também não é obrigado a ter uma
tirolesza para sair por cima. Ele tá
encravado.
Tá vendo?
Quando a gente fala na situação de
encravamento,
quando a gente fala na situação de
encravamento, a pessoa não tem por onde
passar, a gente vai aplicar a regra do
direito de vizinhança chamado
passagem.
Passagem
o quê?
Forçada,
Roberta, que diabo é isso? Uma coisa que
vive caindo em prova, que tem previsão
aqui, ó,
no 1285,
que diz: "O dono do prédio, quando a lei
fala prédio, é o imóvel. O dono do
prédio que não tiver acesso à via
pública, eis que o nosso Mário está sem
acesso à via pública, que ele não vai
conseguir passar pelas árvores. Tá
vendo?
Nascente ou porto pode, mediante
pagamento de indenização cabal,
constranger o vizinho a lhe dar
passagem, cujo rumo será judicialmente
fixado.
Sofrerá o constrangimento o vizinho cujo
imóvel mais natural e facilmente se
prestar à passagem. Se ocorrer a
alienação parcial do prédio, de modo que
uma das partes perca o acesso à via
pública nascente ao porto, o
proprietário da outra deve tolerar a
passagem. Aplica-se o disposto no
parágrafo antecedente, ainda quando
antes da alienação existia passagem
através do imóvel vizinho. Então aqui a
gente tem uma situação de passagem
forçada. Se a banca falar encravamento,
passagem forçada. situação diferente
é o fenômeno da servidão
de passagem. Gente, servidão é um
direito real,
tá? A servidão é um direito real e por
ser direito realistro.
Registro,
tá? Aí imagina aqui, ó. Vamos lá.
Tá aqui, ó, as árvores.
Área verde muito grande,
cheio de cobre e onça. Não tem como
passar por lá. Não tem como passar por
lá, tá?
Só que bem aqui passa a pista.
Passa a pista que vem para cá. A pista
vem para cá.
Aí bem aqui a gente tem
as áreas
aí, tipo, a pista vem para cá, vem para
cá. Tem pista para todo lado aqui, ó.
Pista para todo lado. Todo lado tem
pista aqui.
Tudo pista, tá vendo?
Tudo pista.
Tudo pista. Tudo pista aqui.
Só que bem aqui é o imóvel do João
e ele sai por aqui. Tem saída por aqui.
Bem aqui
é o do José.
E ele tem saída por aqui, tá vendo?
E esse grandão aqui é o do Antônio,
que ele tem saída por aqui. Eu vou botar
as saídas de vermelho.
Tem saída, saída, saída.
Só que o que que rola?
O centro da cidade tá aqui, ó.
o centro da cidade e a pista principal é
essa daqui.
A principal é essa daqui.
O João, olha a linha que ele tem que
andar. O João, ele sai daqui, desce
aqui, vem aqui, vem aqui, vem aqui para
chegar aqui. Tá vendo? É longe para um
caramba.
Aí o João fala: "Antônio,
poxa, ao invés de eu ter que dar essa
volta inteira do caramba,
deixa eu passar por aqui,
viu?
Deixa eu passar por aqui."
E o Antônio fala: "Deixo, que lindo,
deixo." Isso aqui é uma servidão de
passagem. O imóvel do Antônio passa a
ser o imóvel serviente,
o imóvel do João dominante,
que utiliza
a utilidade
da passagem. Isso serve, por exemplo,
também para retirar água, etc. Não
confunda passagem forçada com servidão
de passagem.
De igual sorte, eu quero que você
entenda que nós temos também
essa parada aqui, ó.
Tem um imóvel grande aqui,
né?
E o imóvel pequenininho aqui.
Esse imóvel grande aqui, esse maior, ele
é o imóvel do João.
E esse imóvel pequenininho é o do José.
O do José tá na frente. E pasm, sabe o
que que tem aqui na frente? O mar.
Deixa eu pegar mais grosso aqui para
desenhar o
mar,
a praia.
E aí eles convencionam entre eles
que o menino
José não vai edificar acima
para atrapalhar
a vista,
a vista do João. Isso aqui, gente, é uma
servidão
de vista. Servidão de vista é uma
servidão não aparente,
tá? E como toda servidão tem registro,
você termina com o desregistro.
Aí já caiu na prova assim: "Ah,
calma que tem que ter riqueza,
é em boa viagem, tem que ter riqueza de
detalhes." Aí o que que acontece aqui? A
servidão de vista é uma situação
na qual,
não tem nada. É uma servidão não
aparente,
tá? É uma servidão não aparente.
Professora,
se o José morre, a servidão está
extinta?
Não. Por quê?
Por
a morte
do dono
do prédio
serviente, que é o do José,
não
extingue
a servidão. Os herdeiros dele vão ter
que continuar respeitando a servidão até
ela terminar.
OK?
Dá o print nessa tela aí. E na última
prova, salvo engano, até caiu sobre
usucapião de servidão. Servidão aparente
pode ser usucapida pelos mesmos
critérios da usucapião normal. Servidão
não aparente, como não tem eh não é dada
ao olho nu.
E eu me recordo que na questão até
passou que a pessoa usava umas
tubulações abaixo, né, subterrâneas para
tirar água. Era uma servidão não
aparente, não vista olho nu, não marcada
por uma obra aparente. Não é possível
capi, tá?
E pra gente
fechar a parte de direito das coisas,
né, essa parte tão linda, maravig,
maravigil,
eu quero que você observe aqui o
seguinte,
olha só que interessante.
É, se eu tenho,
se eu tenho
a propriedade ribeirinha, né? Tá aqui o
rio passando,
o rio passando. Aí eu tenho a
propriedade do A
propriedade do B.
a propriedade do A,
a propriedade do B.
Se sai um piloquinho de terra daqui e
vai grudando aqui, sai daqui e vai
grudando aqui, sai daqui, vai grudando
aqui, vai daqui, vai grudando aqui, de
modo a
reduzir a propriedade de A, tá vendo? E
aumentar a propriedade de B.
com o deslocamento da Terra.
Se isso for de maneira lenta, a gente
tem a aluvião.
Aluvião. Olha o L
de lenta.
Olha o L de lenta. Não gera indenização.
Agora, se sai um pilô cão de terra de um
lado,
gruda aqui no outro, de modo a diminuir
a propriedade do Aumentar a propriedade
do B
de maneira violenta, o pilocão de terra
violento,
a gente tem o fenômeno da avulção.
O que que a banca vai te perguntar?
Avulsão
ou V de vi o lento.
Sai o pilocão de terra de um lado e
gruda no outro, aumentando a propriedade
de um, diminuindo a propriedade do
outro. A banca vai querer saber qual que
tem indenização. Onde é que tem
indenização? Na avulção. Olha o cifrão
aqui, ó. Tá? Aluvião é lento, não
indeniza. A vulsão é violento, indeniza.
Beleza.
Olha esse outro, essa outra parada aqui.
Dá o print aí nessa tela. Tá me
acabando. Dá o print.
Olha essa parada aqui.
Le.
Roberta, que que é a laje? Eu tenho uma
construção base.
Eu tenho uma construção base
e eu permito lajes
para cima ou para baixo.
Eu tenho aqui a possibilidade de
construir a laje um,
que é do lajeário
um.
Aí a laje dois,
que é do lajeário
do a gente vai criando unidades
autônomas. Então, por exemplo, a base é
do João,
que é o proprietário da construção base.
O lajeário um é o José. O lajeário dois,
a Maria.
O João, ele quer construir uma terceira
laje. Veja, para construção da laje, eu
tenho que ter a autorização de todos os
lajeários.
Todos têm que autorizar. O José, a
Maria, caiu uma questão dessa. O João
teve um outro filho, queria, ele tinha
três filhos no casamento, ele fez lajes
para os três filhos. E aí ele apareceu
uma filha fora do casamento. Ele queria
construir uma outra laje acima de tudo
para ela. E aí os filhos não
autorizaram. Beleza, não vão autorizar
porque os lajeários precisam autorizar.
Isso são lajes de sobreelevação,
que é o o mais tradicional, mas também
existe laje de infrapartição,
que é a laje no subsolo, tá? Se a
construção base der, eu também posso
ter. Só que o que tem um,
[limpando a garganta]
perdão, tem um ponto aqui interessante
no direito de laje,
que é a extinção dela, que eu vou
colocar aqui para você agora, ó.
Olha
aqui o 1510
e
a ruína da construção base implica em
extinção do direito real de laje.
Se este tivesse sido construído no
subsolo, não gera extinção se ele não
destruir também, né? E se a construção
base for reconstruída no prazo de 5
anos? Então o seguinte, se cair a
construção base aqui do João, a
desmorona tudo, menos a do Antônio, se
permanecer intacta. Então, se cai a
construção base, você tem a extinção da
laje do José e da Maria, que são lajes
de sobreelevação.
Agora, se a construção base for refeita
no prazo de 5 anos, volta o direito da
laje, do José e da Maria, que podem
reconstruir, né, eh, a a as suas as suas
respectivas lajes. Detalhe, isso não
afasta o direito de eventual reparação
contra o culpado pela ruína.
Porque gente, eu vou construindo lag, eu
tenho que, né, pelo amor de Deus, eu
tenho que ter a, como é que fala? A, a
garantia de que não vai cair a tem que
aguentar a obra.
E só uma última observação.
Última observação.
Imagina o seguinte,
João tá lá passeando.
É bem minha cara isso aqui. João tá lá
passeando. Aí o João acha
um doguinho bonitinho.
Ele acha um doguinho
de ninguém.
Um doguinho de ninguém. Uma res no lus.
Ele pode pegar o doguinho para ele?
Pode. Ele tá adquirindo a propriedade da
coisa móvel. O nome disso é ocupação.
Ocupação é uma forma de aquisição da
propriedade do bem móvel.
Situação diferente é o João que tá lá
passeando
encontra
o doguinho.
Encontra o doguinho perdido,
a resderelicta.
Ele encontra o doguinho perdido.
Se ele encontra o o doguinho perdido,
ele tem que devolver pro dono. Isso aqui
é achamento
de coisa perdida ou também chamado
achamento de coisa vaga.
Ele tem que promover a devolução. Ele
não pode ficar para ele. E quem acha
coisa dos outros perdido tem direito a
uma recompensa
não inferior a 5% do valor do bem,
tá? São coisas diferentes.
Agora, se você encontra a placa de uma
pessoa falando: "Prometo a recompensa de
X para quem encontrar o meu cachorro".
Aí já é um ato unilateral chamado
promessa de recompensa e a pessoa tem
que cumprir a recompensa. OK? Vamos dar
o print nossos no nosso material de
hoje. Que caderno incrível que a gente
fez hoje de direito das coisas. Dá o
print aí pra gente.
Tô muito feliz com o nosso material de
hoje.
Dá o print aí pra gente.
2 1
2 1.
Olha o quadro da Usucapião. 3 2 1.
O caso do João, gente, pelo amor de
Deus, da evção, vai dando print.
Passagem forçada,
servidão de vista.
Olha lá, aluvião e avulção.
Lage,
ocupação e achamento de coisa vaga. Ai,
que coisa linda. Professora, acha para
mim ocupação.
Vamos lá. Vou botar aqui para você
ocupação.
Olha lá, quem se assenhorar de coisa sem
dono para logo lhe adquire a
propriedade, não sendo esta defesa por
lei. Tá beleza? Artigo negócio 1263.
E um beijo para você. Espero que você
tenha curtido o nosso encontro de hoje.
Nosso próximo encontro será quinta-feira
sobre responsabilidade civil.
Estamos junto. Fico muito feliz a cada
momento que a gente termina o nosso
encontro. E deixa eu te falar, vai dar
certo, eu tenho certeza,
porque somente terá direito à vista mais
fantástica aquele que suportar o
processo de escalada. E o processo de
escalada é difícil, é doloroso, é
complicado, é solitário, mas eu tenho
certeza que vai valer muito a pena e eu
tenho certeza que em breve você vai
estar com a sua carteira na mão, podendo
advogar. Um beijo enorme para você. Vou
mandar um coraçãozinho aqui agora no
chat de vocês. Esse é o meu canal
direito como nunca se viu. Pode clicar
aí, tem várias aulas lá. E também tô no
Instagram @Robertaqueiroz.
Eu vou postar lá no nos links da minha,
se você quiser um caderno completo de
direito civil, eu vou postar para você
se inscrever no nosso encontro que nós
teremos de revisão de véspera e você vai
receber um caderno impecável de direito
civil, todo desenhado, meu especial. É
só clicar no link que eu vou postar lá,
tá? Beijo, beijo para vocês. Até a
próxima. Tchau, tchau.
Cadê a vinheta?
[música]